and with the increase in covid cases as
well as the flu and the cold season
it may be tough to determine what you're
actually sick from
8 news now reporter kate houston spoke
to a doctor about how to tell the
difference
as the weather changes in southern
nevada doctors are challenged with
differentiating between symptoms of a
cold
flu and now covid19 if you wake up with
itchy eyes or a runny nose it could be
allergies which usually taper off in
cold weather
congestion in your nose and a mild cough
could mean you have a cold
allergies and colds tend to be
relatively mild
they're annoying and they're incredibly
unpleasant
but people tend not to feel really
beaten down
by those kinds of symptoms dr andrew
eisen says it can be very difficult to
distinguish between the symptoms of the
flu
and covid19 early on so it may require
testing
both have overlapping symptoms such as
fever body aches fatigue or cough
dr eisen adds that preventative measures
such as a flu vaccine
are crucial and the key is really to do
as many of the things as we can
to layer on top of one another to
decrease the risk
not only can it prevent the need for
medical treatment or lessen the severity
of your illness but it will also
alleviate some pressure off local
hospitals
when you layer in flu and covid that's a
perfect storm for
overflowing and hospitals being
overwhelmed with a surge of patients
that we just can't handle
people with mild symptoms of the flu or
covid19 are encouraged to have clear
communication with their primary care
physician
many do telemedicine severe symptoms
such as a persistent high fever or
difficulty breathing
should be addressed immediately kate
houston 8 news now
hospitals do tend to see an uptick in
pneumonia cases this time of year as
well
now symptoms would be a really
persistent cough that comes from deep in
the chest
paired with localized chest pain